>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Here's the background
on Allegra Goodman.
She was born in Brooklyn,
grew up in Honolulu.
She went to Harvard and the day she
graduated was the day her first book
was published.
And Allegra Goodman was off.
She got a PhD in English
Lit at Stanford
where she wrote her second book.
She got married, moved to Cambridge,
Massachusetts where
she has had 4 children
and written 5 novels including
National Book Award finalist,
"Kaaterskill Falls."
Her work has appeared
in Good Housekeeping,
Slate and American Scholar.
She was named by the New Yorker as
one of the 20 best writers under 40.
She is also the recipient
of a Whiting Award
and the Salon magazine
award for fiction.
Those are the details of
her very successful career
but it really doesn't tell
you much about the experience
of reading her work,
of immersing herself--
oneself in her vivid
beautifully realized worlds,
because Allegra Goodman is a
writer who is observant and wise.
She is a powerful writer who
gently lays out detailed mosaics
that reveal the inner workings
of small communities and she is
that rarity of fluid writer
who stays out of the way.
I discovered Allegra Goodman
through the pages of the New Yorker
where her short stories about
the Markowitz Family gave notice
that this was a distinctive voice
who was an astute observer
bringing the complexities
of Jewish-American
family life to life.
Her novel, "Kaaterskill Falls"
only confirmed her quiet authority
and keen perception as she
describe the daily routines
which create reassuring rhythms
for a small orthodox community
who vacationed each summer
in a Kaaterskill town.
Examining religious life with
the subtlety rarely found
in recent fiction, she also
demonstrated with great tenderness,
the comfort and limitations
of weaving the individual life
into the fabric of
the larger community.
Allegra Goodman brings that same
thoroughness in telling detail
to her latest novel, "The Cookbook
Collector" which looks at the 1999,
2000 dot-com bubble
and its aftermath.
At the center of this book are the
Bach sisters, 23-year-old Jess,
an environmental activist working in
an antiquarian bookstore in Berkeley
and Emily, an overachiever
in Silicon Valley
who is making a fortune at the
crest of the dot-com craze.
And yes, there's a playful
connection to Jane Austen's "Sense
and Sensibility" with
pragmatic driven
and rational Emily counterpoised
against dreamy idealistic Jess.
And because there is a-- this
is a Allegra Goodman after all,
there is also a Bialystok rabbi
whose hearty faith adds his own
particular zest to this novel about
appetite, temptation, and doubt.
"The Cookbook Collector"
is a modern novel, however,
set firmly in the digital age.
It's a techy paradise
where a Microsoft fortune
is considered old money
and Goodman captures that
world with humor and subtlety,
as well as a contagious affection
for the character she creates.
Her character struggle with
questions about what really counts
in a confusing world where stock
prices soar and crash in the space
of months, redwoods
are ripe for the ax
and rare books are often
too valuable to read.
Her descriptions of modern
life reveals its ambiguities,
some subtle, others not so much.
As in all her work, the question
of how to behave ethically
in a world filled with temptations
is central and for Allegra Goodman,
it's always the questioning
that's important.
She appreciates, I think,
that neither the choices we make nor
the values we live by are perfect.
They're flawed.
Often the recipes we follow
don't work or the meal turns
out differently from what
we may have expected.
That's the human condition and it's
one Allegra Goodman illustrates
beautifully in "The
Cookbook Collector."
With the searching moral
intelligence, a singular gift
for creating vivid
miniaturized worlds
and beautifully nuanced prose.
She's given us a novel that
ripens slowly like a summer peach
and it's our pleasure to
savor every juicy bite.
Please welcome, Allegra Goodman.
[ Applause ]
>> Well, thank you for
that beautiful introduction
and thank you for coming.
I feel a little breath of air coming
through this tent and I have to say,
the stay in this little breath
of air reminds me of home
and I speak this is
a Hawaiian, you know.
[Laughter] The little
trade wind coming
through in this hot humid day.
Well, I'll you a little bit
about my book, my newest book,
"The Cookbook Collector" and I'll
talk a little bit about my process
as a writer and how I went
about writing this novel.
Then I'll read you one
paragraph from the book just
so you get a tiny taste of what
it's like and then I'd love
to answer any questions
that you might have.
So, different books of mine
begin in different ways.
Sometimes, I come up
with a first line
for a book, sometimes it's an image.
In this case, my idea for
"The Cookbook Collector" began
with an observation, a personal
observation which is that,
although I love to read
cookbooks and I collect them.
I actually have a large
collection of cookbooks.
I don't actually cook myself.
[Laughter] I began to be-- become
interested in this phenomenon
of people who read and
love and buy cookbooks
but don't actually cook and, you
know, for me since I don't cook,
you know, the harder the
cookbook, the better you know?
[Laughter] I love all
the hard steps,
the rare ingredients,
you know, bring it on.
I'm not actually gonna
go shopping for them, so.
So I began with this idea of
what would it be like to write
about somebody, a character
who collects cookbooks
but does not cook, actually
doesn't go into the kitchen really.
From this, I sort of-- this
idea grew into thinking
about rare cookbooks, not just the
beautiful coffee table cookbooks
or the ones that we--
the contemporary ones,
the new ones that you might be able
to buy here but early cookbook,
rare ones, early women's
cookbooks, 18th century cookbooks,
17th century cookbooks, 16th century
cookbooks from Eastern Europe.
I live in Cambridge,
Massachusetts and around the corner
from me is a library called,
the Schlesinger Library
which belongs to Harvard.
Once upon a time, it
belonged to Radcliffe.
And this library is-- has a world
class collection of cookbooks,
so you know, this is in the
category of write about what--
you know, write local, think local.
I went to this library and talked
to the librarian there and I said,
"I'm a novelist and I'm interested
in doing research in this library
and research into rare cookbooks."
And she introduced me to a
scholar named, Barbara Whitten
who is a cookbook expert and I
sat down with Barbara Whitten
and I said, "You know,
I'm not a scholar.
I'm not sort of a typical
kind of researcher."
I always tell people this to
disarm them when I do research.
I say, "I'm not like a
journalist or historian.
I actually work away from the
truth, you know, not toward it."
Sometimes, my attempts to disarm
people actually frighten them a
little I think.
So Barbara Whitten and I sat down.
She's here in 80s and a world
renowned authority on cookbooks
and I said, "Essentially what I'd
like you to help me with is to--
for my novel to help me curate a
fictional collection of cookbooks."
So Barbara said, "Oh,
what's your budget?"
[Laughter] And I said,
money is no object,
you know fictional collection.
So, we began talking about
what books I might put
in this fictional collection which
was going to become a character
and my, as yet unwritten novel
and I called this research--
it's also a form of procrastination
[laughter] which seems to be key
to my process, my writing process.
And she said-- she began to sort of
get into the spirit of it and said,
"This cookbook is so rare.
There are only 2 left in the world,"
but if they were third, you know.
"This cookbook is so rare that
the [inaudible] has a facsimile
you know?
And at one point, as we
we're batting around ideas
and I was writing down titles
that I thought I could include
in this private mysterious
cookbook collection,
she started fanning herself
with some papers and she said,
"You realized, Allegra,
I'm consumed with lust."
[Laughter] Research is really fun
and I thought I want you in my book.
I want you.
I wanna import you into my book.
Because really what I was interested
and when I was talking to her was
to think about and discover
the psychology of collecting.
My subject is always
people, not things.
That's why my book is called,
"The Cookbook Collector"
and not the cookbook collection.
The collection is a character in the
book but what really interested me--
in me-- what really interested
me was the sort of lust
that the collector has
and what that's all about.
Now at the same time that I was
pursuing this cookbook idea,
I had another idea which had
been growing on me for sometime.
I'd always been interested
in writing a novel set during
the dot-com boom and bust.
>> So essentially, in
writing a historical novel
about the very recent past,
I'm talking 1999, 1998,
a historical novel about a period
that we've all lived through
and think that we remember.
And I started thinking about, how
did these 2 ideas fit together?
How might they fit together
in a book and I thought,
I'm writing a novel
that's really about hunger,
the hunger for collecting,
the hunger for food,
the hunger for money which was
very much part of that time period,
the hunger for knowledge and new
technology, the latest thing,
the next thing, the hunger
for fame, the hunger for love
and connection with other people.
I was writing a book about different
sorts of hunger, different sorts
of desire, so that sort of where the
beginning of this novel came from.
Once I had the idea for this book,
I began what I guess I could call
as my writing process which seems
to involve a year of floundering
around having no idea what I'm
doing which I take lots of notes.
The more notes I take, the more I
feel that I'm getting things done.
I write notes.
I think about the names
of my characters.
I write genealogies for them.
I write down all kinds
of information that's not
gonna end up in the book.
Somehow, it seems to help me.
And I do charts with arrows
between the characters.
The charts for this book
got bigger and bigger
until I actually got those
presentation-sized post-its,
the really big ones and--
that you can put on the wall
and I wrote the names of
the characters with arrows
so that the chart looks
kind of like a brain.
And again, this made
me feel scientific
like I was doing something.
And I did some research
in the Schlesinger
Library during this time.
I went and looked at
some of those titles
that Barbara Whitten
had mentioned to me.
I held these books in my hands,
these gorgeous rare cookbooks found
in leather with gilt-edged
pages, their archaic language
in this beautiful reading
room Harvard.
So you know, I do-- I did a fair
amount of research in that sense.
I would also say though
that 90 percent
of my research is really
in my imagination.
It's just the tiny amount that
I do when I go to a place,
look at a book, talk to a person.
Most of it really has to do with--
most of it, I'm probably doing
when I'm asleep and dreaming.
So it's an imaginative
research, an imaginative process.
And I would say the relationship
between a research and the book is
like everyday life to a dream.
The book is more like
the dream that develops.
After I had floundered around for
quite a bit of time, I plunged in
and began writing my novel about
this 2 sisters, Emily and Jess.
Emily the older pragmatic one
as Jill mentioned and Jess,
5 years younger, much
more whimsical.
Emily is the CEO of a startup
company in Silicon Valley.
Her younger sister is a
graduate student in philosophy,
still trying to find
her way in life.
who works at an antiquarian
bookstore which is where she comes
across the rare cookbook
collection and also where she comes
across a book collector
and book dealer named,
George who is quite
interested in her.
I began my work by
writing during the day.
I have 4 children, so I write
while they're at school.
And I write a lot of
notes and outlines
which is I say makes
me feel organized.
It's a bit like when you
write all those to-do lists,
it sort of makes you feel
like you're in control
of an uncontrollable process
or an uncontrollable life.
And I changed all my
outlines all along the way.
I have a lot of interruptions
in my life especially
because I have children and with
this book which is an ambitious book
with many layers, I found that a new
way of dealing with interruptions
that I hadn't found before
and I share with any of you
who are working on projects,
during-- when you get interrupted,
long projects where you have to sort
of keep the faith and keep moving.
I began everyday's
work writing this book
by rewriting what I had
written the day before,
before I went on to the new--
to new work and I found that
this helped me keep going
and keep focused and also
maintain the continuity,
the voice of the book as I went.
During this period, when I was
writing the book, when I finally got
down to it, you know the first
hundred pages are always the
hardest, but I finally sort
of gotten my momentum going.
I did a trip to Berkeley, California
where half of my book is set
and did some location
scouting there.
I googled Bernard Maybeck houses,
this beautiful Californian architect
and went-- drove around in a rented
car up in the Berkeley Hills trying
to think about where George lived
and where he might park his car,
what his house looked like in
relation to the neighborhood.
And I began to write
in different places.
Another thing that I would recommend
to those of you who might feel
like you're getting a little
stuck writing in the same place
at the same desk everyday.
I began to go to the places
where I had set my work.
Later on towards the end of
my book, there's an argument
between the 2 sisters which
takes place at a Home Depot.
So, I drove to my local Home Depot,
not far from my house
with my little netbook.
And since the 2 sisters were
arguing there at the store,
I wrote the scene in the store.
I sat on one of those
orange rolling ladders.
[Laughter] And with my little--
I was typing away, you know.
And because I wanted to be
with the real paint chips
and the real fake terra cotta
flower pots and all of that.
And a man did approach me as I was
sitting there on the rolling ladder
and say-- and he said,
"Do you work here?"
[Laughter] And I said, "Yes."
[Laughter].
But you know-- and like many of
the people who work at Home Depot,
I couldn't help him anyway so.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Sometimes, like all
writers, I get frustrated.
My work was slowly at
times and there were--
there are scenes in this book
that I rewrote many, many times.
There're also scenes in this
book that came more easily to me
where I somehow got under the
surface and got into that sort
of underwater territory where I
was completely absorbed in my work
and I think that probably if
you talk to other writers here
at the festival, they would
say to you that there are sort
of these moments where you
are completely absorbed
and completely caught
up and it's in that--
those are the times when
writing is really fun.
I work sometimes at a cafe near my
house and I had a moment like that
where I was writing a scene and
I really was into it and I looked
up from my table which was by the
window and it was a winter day
in Boston and it gets dark
very early and I looked up
and it was dark and I was really
thirsty and I looked around
and I didn't have a drink.
So, I went to the barista,
the counter and I said, "Oh,
I think a hot chocolate
and I didn't--
don't have it" and she said,
"When did you order it?"
And I looked at my watch and
I said, "Three hours ago."
[Laughter] And she said, "We called
and called for the hot chocolate
and nobody came so we dumped it."
And I said, "I'm sorry.
I was really into my work.
I lost track of the time."
And this woman or girl, she
looked like she was about 16,
said, "Dude, I feel you."
[Laughter] And brought
me another one.
[Laughter] So you know, I mean
you know, you should believe it
when people say writing is hard.
It's also fun, if you
keep your sense of humor.
After I'm done with the
whole manuscript and I've--
in revising as I go along, I do a
lot of revision especially cutting.
I've got more and more
ruthless as I've gotten older
and I will cut and
trim wherever I can.
I revised the whole thing a
couple of times before I send it
to my editor so I feel that--
you know, I feel I can
show my face to her.
So, that's a bit about my writing
process and then I'm just going
to read you a paragraph from the
book, so you can hear what it sounds
like and then I'd love to answer
any questions that you have about,
"The Cookbook Collector"
or any of my other work.
So the paragraph I'm going to
read to you comes from a scene
where George, the bookseller
has had dinner with his friends
and they've left and it's late,
late at night and he's thinking
about Jess who works for him
who is much younger that he is
and he really likes her and he's
imagining-- he's imagining her.
Sentimentally, George
thought of Jess.
Irrationally, he imagined her.
Sadly, he despaired of having her
but this was not a
question of pursuit.
Raj would laugh at him and
Nick would look as scams.
But his fantasies were
nurturing, not predatory.
If he could have Jess,
he would feed her.
Laughable, antique, confusingly
paternal, he longed to nourish her
with clementines and pears in
season, fresh whole wheat bread
and butter, wild strawberries,
comte cheese, fresh figs
and oily Marcona almonds,
tender yellow beets.
He would sear red meat, if she would
let him, and grill spring lamb,
cut the thorns off artichokes
and dip the leaves in fresh aoli,
poach her fish, thick Dover
Sole and wine and shallots,
julienne potatoes, and
roast a whole chicken
with lemon slices under the skin.
He would serve a salad of heirloom
tomatoes and fresh mozzarella
and just-picked basil, serve
her and watch her savor dinner,
pour for her, and watch her drink.
>> That would be enough for him.
To find her plums in season
and perfect nectarines,
velvet apricots, dark
succulent duck.
To bring her all these
things and watch her eat.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Anyone-- anyone with a question.
I see somebody coming.
>> Yes, Ms. Goodman, having
read Kaaterskill Falls
in which a book collection also
plays no small part and intending
to read this book and I mean also
just heard David Petroski talked
for 4 years and-- or Henry
Petroski talk, pardon me,
in which time when
asked about e-books.
I would like you-- to question you
as to what will it mean to lust
after electronic publishing.
>> [Laughter].
What is it like to a lust
after electronic publishing.
Ooh, I think it would
be a different sort of--
it might be a different
sort of feeling actually.
I have to think about that.
I don't think lust-- I don't think
lust really comes into it quite yet.
And certainly that's what my
book collector, George would say.
You know, I think there's
a reason that in Facebook,
you've liked something, you
don't love something or lust
for something, you like it, so may
be we just like electronic fiction.
We don't love it or lust for it.
Yes?
>> I was wondering who encouraged
you to write since you're
such a young writer, it's obvious
that there's gotta be many people
encouraging you along the way.
>> Thank you for calling me young.
[Laughter] I was encouraged
by my family
and when I was a really young
writer, I used to read my work aloud
to my parents and my sister and
especially funny stuff that--
which would them laugh and
that encouraged me the most.
And I always felt the
best thing for me would be
when my mother was laughing so
much that tears were streaming
down her face and I thought,
Oh, I got something there.
[Laughter] Yes?
>> I know that like
myself as aspiring writer,
I always like a certain
character more than others.
Is there any character
in your new book
that you like more than the rest?
>> Oh, my children, my children,
I can't-- you know, she's--
I love all the characters here
especially the unsympathetic ones,
you know.
I think perhaps George,
George in this book.
I felt like the highest
praise for me
when I finished this book was my
agent read them book and she said
to me-- we're talking about
George, the antiquarian bookseller
and she said, "Where's my George?"
[Laughter] And I thought, "Hmm."
[Laughter] Good question.
Yes?
>> Hello, good to see you again.
I was wondering since in the
novel, "Intuition" is about science
and science post-docs and you
and your husband sort
of lived in that world.
So, I was wondering how much
of that was based on you
and David's experiences and
how the novel was received
by the MIT science community?
>> Well, my husband is a computer
scientist and "Intuition" is
about biologist, so you know--
so I felt very safe and actually,
my husband was a little offended.
He said, "Why didn't you write
about computer scientist,
we're so interesting, you know?"
[Laughter] And that was really the
feeling of a lot of his colleagues.
But great interest
in the MIT community
and in the scientific community
in that book and it was a lot
of fun having written about
a laboratory in crisis.
[ Pause ]
>> Anyone else?
[ Silence ]
>> Well, thank you so
much for having me here.
Bye.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.